hi my name is curtis bechtel
i'll be talking about delegated
stochastic probing
which is joint work with shad and digni
to motivate our problem i want to talk
about transportation
we can imagine for some city but the
city mayor wants to design
a new public transportation network
they might delegate this problem to an
expert contractor who knows more about
how to design such a network than they
do
the contractor probably has other
interests involved
they may prefer designs that put bus
stops at their own headquarters
or designs that improve the roads in
their own neighborhood regardless of
whether these are good for the city or
not
so the mayor asks us how to incentivize
the contractor
to produce a design that's good for the
city rather than just good for the
contractor
we could call this problem delegated
search and it's a principal
agent type problem in which the agent
searches for solutions
to the principal's problem and the
principal cannot search for their own
solutions for whatever reason
we take inspiration from the work of
kleinberg and kleinberg
and delegated search approximates
efficient search
in their paper they describe a
distributional model
in which the agent can sample k
independent solutions
from a single distribution and then they
must propose one of those
samples to the principle
they also describe a binary model in
which there are many different potential
solutions
and each one has a fixed utility for
both agents
but randomized feasibility and checking
the feasibility
of an element incurs costs to both the
principal
and the agent and they show that for
both
models the principal can design a
mechanism
which gives them a one-half
approximation for a very particular
sense
of approximation that we'll describe
later
as an overview of our results we start
by modeling delegation
as a game theoretic version of
stochastic probing problems
defined broadly we then show that simple
mechanisms are just as good as general
mechanisms
and this is much like the revelation
principle
we show that delegate stochastic probing
can be reduced to a combination
of profit inequalities and adaptivity
gaps of a particular character
and then using this along with known
results we get the following two
corollaries
we show that we have constant factor
approximations
for a very large class of these
delegation problems
secondly we show that there's a one-half
approximation
for a generalization of the
distributional model
of kleinberg and kleinberg this is a
generalization
in which we allow heterogeneous
distributions
finally we show that randomized
mechanisms sometimes outperform
deterministic ones
but not in general and this provides
evidence
that maybe randomized mechanisms perform
just as well and no better than
deterministic ones
in the worst case
we'll start by defining a non-game
theoretic
problem called stochastic probing
broadly this is composed of a set of
elements e
where each element has a random value x
sub e there's an
outer constraint limiting the set of
elements we can probe
and there's an inner constraint limiting
the sets of elements
we can accept the procedure in this
problem
is to probe elements subject to the
outer constraint so the elements we
probe
have to be inside have to be feasible in
the other constraint
and accept a subset of probed elements
this time
the set of elements we accept has to be
subject to the inner constraint
our goal is to maximize the sum of the
values of the elements we accept
and this is an expectation of course
as an example we can consider the
following graph
this is a stochastic probing problem in
which elements
are the nodes of the graph our outer
constraint our probing constraint
is a four uniform metroid so we can
probe at most
four elements and our inner constraint
is the independent sets of the graph so
we can accept
any independent set i haven't described
the distributions of the elements
we can assume that they're known
if we were really trying to solve this
problem but for our purposes we'll just
ignore that
so we might imagine we start by probing
element a to reveal a value of 5
and then element e to reveal a value of
8
and then d and then f in that order
now once we've seen all of these values
now we have to choose an independent set
to accept and the best choice here are
the elements
a d and f
now it turns out that kleinberg and
kleinberg delegated essentially the
following stochastic probing problem
we can imagine a problem in which their
k identically distributed elements
there's no outer constraint
at all we're allowed to probe all
elements
and there's a one uniform metroid in
your constraint
and this is just the stochastic probing
problem corresponding to their
distributional model
we can also imagine other types of
stochastic probing problems
that we might want to delegate for
example a transportation problem could
be defined as follows
we have some number of bus network
designs
and some other number of subway network
designs
we have a total fixed amount of time
available to us
and each design costs a certain amount
of time to evaluate
so we want to evaluate as many as we can
but we need to be strategic about it
and ultimately we want at most one bus
network and at most one
subway network and in general
we may want to delegate arbitrary
stochastic probing problems
so this leads us to define our model as
a delegated version
of stochastic probing as we defined it
earlier
this consists of a ground set of
elements e
where each element has a known
distribution
over utilities x for the principal and y
for the agent
we allow x and y to be arbitrarily
correlated
but each distribution from different
elements must be independent of each
other
we also have an outer constraint on the
set of elements that can be probed
this is the probing constraint and again
an inner constraint on the set of
elements that can be accepted
as a solution by the principle this is
the accepting constraint
our goal is to design the mechanism
maximizing the principal's total utility
for accepted elements in expectation
we take the perspective of the principle
here
just to some brief notation before we
get started we call an element along
with its utilities
so the triple e x sub e and y sub e
we call that an outcome we call
set s of outcomes whose elements
are feasible in the inner constraint a
solution so anything that the principal
could accept
is a solution
omega here is the set of all solutions
and we also write little x and little y
as utility functions so for set f
of elements x of f is just the utility
that we expect to get well sorry the
utility that we get from those elements
and for a set s of outcomes x of s
is the utility from those outcomes
to solve this problem we propose the
following mechanism
it starts with the principle committing
to a family
r of acceptable solutions and this means
that
if the agent proposes a solution inside
r
the principal commits to accepting it
and if the agent proposes one outside of
r
the principal commits to rejecting it
the agent in response probes elements
adaptively subject to the outer
constraint and once they're done probing
or while they're probing they receive
the set of outcomes
s the agent then proposes a solution
t which is a subset of s
and if that solution t is acceptable to
the principal
and the principal accepts it and both
principal and agent get their respective
utilities
for that solution otherwise
they both get zero the principal rejects
their solution
and we call this the status quo nothing
changes
as an example of this in practice we can
consider the same graph from before
where the elements are nodes the outer
constraint
is a four uniform metroid so again we
probe at most four elements
and the inner constraint are the
independent sets of the graph
so we can accept any independent set
and a reasonable strategy for the
principle you might guess
is to set some kind of threshold so the
principle says they'll accept
any solution s where their utility for s
is at least 10. the agent in response
probes elements a then e
d and c for example receiving the
following
utility pairs now
c d is the principal's favorite solution
from the available solutions and ae
a totally different solution is the
agent's favorites
but notice that ae is not acceptable to
the principal
because the principal's utility is only
seven
therefore we can the agent will try
to propose their favorite from among the
principal's
acceptable solutions in this case a.d
is the agent's favorite acceptable
solution
and it's really a compromise between the
two the principal didn't get their
favorite and the agent also didn't get
their favorite
so therefore the agent will propose that
solution
and the principal will accept because
they committed to accepting it
so we call this mechanism a single
proposal mechanism
and it turns out to be actually very
powerful uh here we'll generalize the
result of kleinberg and kleinberg
which says that single proposal
mechanisms are actually
just as powerful as a much broader class
of signaling mechanisms
and we're transforming the result into
one that applies
for our model we can define signaling
mechanisms
as one for which the agent can send any
signal they want
and the principle will then transform
the signal into a solution
by a transformation function that the
principal chose
and we get the following lemma that's
that says that for any signaling
mechanism
for our delegation problem there exists
an equivalent
single proposal mechanism so we can
consider without loss of generality
single proposal mechanisms from here on
out
now for our purposes we're interested in
approximately optimal mechanisms
and we define approximately as this
delegation gap delegation gap is a
comparison
of the principal's delegated utility
which is the utility they get
when they're delegating and their
non-delegate utility
which is the principal's expected
utility when they
search on their own using the same
constraints as the agent
this is the same as the utility when
they solve the stochastic probing
problem
associated with the delegation problem
and so the delegation gap is just the
ratio it's the worst case ratio
between these two quantities the optimal
delegated utility
and optimal non-delegated utility
and this answers the question how much
does the principal still get
when they delegate to that agent
as a detour before we get to our first
results uh we need to talk about profit
inequalities
in particular the generalized profit
inequality problem
consists of a set of elements e where
each element has a non-negative random
utility
x b we have another constraint system
m and the procedure for this problem
is for an adversary to order elements in
advance
then the gambler learns the realization
of each element
in the order set by the adversary
the gambler upon seeing each element
must irrevocably accept or reject that
element
such that the set of elements they
accept is feasible in the constraint
this must be done in an online fashion
the gambler aims to maximize the sum of
the elements they accept
and we also have a prophet who plays the
same game as the gambler
but they know all realizations in
advance so they always get the maximum
possible utility then an alpha profit
alpha factor profit inequality for this
problem
says that the gambler has a strategy
with expected utility
at least alpha of the profits expected
utility we're interested
in two particularly strong
variants of the generalized profit
inequality
first our adversary is called the
almighty adversary
it's much more powerful than the
standard adversary
and this one knows the gambler's
strategy random variables
and the realizations of all elements in
advance
therefore the adversary can simulate the
gambler's strategy
perfectly and choose a truly worst case
ordering
for the gambler we're also interested in
greedy strategies
for the gambler we restrict the types of
strategies that the gambler can use
in this case a greedy strategy is
defined by a downward closed family
we call a of solutions or subsets of
elements and their realizations
the gambler employing a greedy strategy
starts with an empty solution
s and at any time when they have
solution s
and they see a new outcome e with
realization x
b they accept that outcome if and only
if
the outcome along with their current
solution is still
in a now we can use
profit inequalities using greedy
strategies against the almighty
adversary
to help solve delegation problems with
no outer constraint
and here we'll use a reduction from
delegation
to these profit inequalities to do so
to see why this might be the case we'll
compare delegation
with profit inequalities and here the
delegating principle
is analogous to the gambler the
non-delegating principle
is analogous to the profits and
the agent is analogous to the adversary
so the delegation problem starts with
the delegating principle
committing to a set r of acceptable
solutions
and the profit inequality starts with
the greedy gambler committing to a
strategy a
then in response the agent can probe all
elements because there's no other
constraint
and they'll learn all realizations of
the elements
for the profit inequality the adversary
always knows all the realizations
for delegation the agent then chooses
what realizations to show to the
principal
and similarly in the profit inequality
the adversary chooses the order
of elements to show to the gambler
finally we have a non-delegating
principle for delegation which
always gets the optimal solution and
this is what we
compare our delegating principle to and
in the profit inequality
the profit always gets the optimal
solution as well
and that's what we compare our greedy
gambler to
formalizing this intuition the
similarities between these two problems
we get the following theorem
which says that there's an approximation
preserving reduction
from our delegation problems without
outer constraints
to profit inequality problems with
greedy strategies against the almighty
adversary
using this theorem we get the following
corollaries
first we show that there are constant
factor strategies
with for delegated stochastic probium
problems that don't have an outer
constraint
and their inner constraint is the
intersection of a constant number
of metroid matching and knapsack
constraints
this follows from the work of feldman's
fenson and zynclusin
in contention resolution schemes they
show that there
are greedy strategies greedy profit
inequalities
that give constant factor results
against an almighty adversary
we also get the second corollary which
says that there's a one-half factor
strategy for delegate stochastic probing
problems
again with no other constraint and the
one uniform
metroid inner constraint and this
generalizes the result
of klein breaking klamberg this time to
heterogeneous
elements heterogeneous distributions
and it follows from the very famous
single choice
threshold rule of samuel khan
now as a detour before we get to our
more general results
for inner and outer constraint
delegation
we need to talk about the adaptivity gap
which is defined for the problem of
stochastic set function
maximization this is composed of
a ground set of elements e where each
element
in e has a random value x sub e and
these
values are independent of each other we
again have a constraint system
m and we have a stochastic set function
which i'll call
u from subsets of elements to
non-negative reals
such that u of a set of elements f is
completely determined
by the random values of those elements
our procedure for this problem is simply
to probe some set of elements
f such that that element that set is
feasible in the constraint
and our goal is to maximize the expected
value of u of f
now we can consider two different types
of strategies for this
problem adaptive strategies which is the
general case
can choose the next element to probe
based on
all of our knowledge from previous
probes
on the other hand we have much more
restrictive non-adaptive strategies
that have to choose the set of elements
they're going to probe in advance
and then they commit to probing all of
the ones that they chose
the adaptivity gap beta measures
the worst case ratio of these two
quantities
the optimal non-adaptive expected value
to the optimal adaptive expected value
and this answers the question
what fraction of the optimal expected
value can we get
when we're only using a non-adaptive
strategy
now we can use the adaptivity gap along
with our previous result
to get delegation gaps for delegation
problems with inner and other
constraints
the basic idea here is to define the
function u
to be the optimal utility that the
non-delegating principle gets
when they probe exactly the elements f
then we can use the adaptivity gap for
the function u
on the constraint on our outer
constraint to find
a set f feasible and add a constraint
that approximately maximizes
u now given the set f
we can consider the restricted
delegation instance
restricted to only the elements in f and
then because
f is feasible in the other constraint
the other constraint is no longer
relevant it no longer
restrains us so now we can use this
to run our previous mechanism which
works
when our delegation problem has no outer
constraint and only
an inner constraint and this is the
basic idea
formalizing this intuition we get the
following theorem
which says that there's a reduction from
delegation problems
that removes the outer constraint losing
only a factor of the adaptivity gap of
weighted rank functions of inner
constraint
on the outer constraint so we lose only
the factor of an adaptivity gap to
remove
the other constraint
as the corollary of this result along
with our previous corollary
we get that there are constant factor
strategies for delegation
for delegation problems with any
downward closed outer constraint
and an inner constraint that's the
intersection of a constant number
of metroids this follows from the work
of bradak singla and zuzik
finally we briefly investigate lottery
mechanisms which are a type of
randomized mechanism
the procedure here is very similar to
our deterministic mechanisms from before
with one slight change the principle
starts by committing to a menu of
distributions of the solutions
rather than before they commit to a menu
over deterministic solutions
in response the agent will still probe
as usual
and then propose one distribution from
the menu rather than proposing
a solution the principal finally
accepts a sample from that distribution
that the agent proposed
we're interested in comparing how how
good
lottery mechanisms are when compared to
deterministic mechanisms
and we do so in the special case of no
outer constraint
and the one uniform metroid in your
constraint
we show that there are some instances
where lottery mechanisms
have a delegation gap of one or
essentially one
whereas deterministic mechanisms have a
gap of one-half
so lottery mechanisms perform much
better
but in some worst-case instances both
mechanisms have a gap
of one-half and this is tight and this
provides evidence that lottery
mechanisms
do not do better than deterministic ones
in the worst case
i'll leave you with some open questions
from our work
first off are these factors tight we
give a bunch of constant factors but
we only know one that's tight in
particular we know that one half is
tight
for instances with no outer constraint
and the one uniform metroid inner
constraint
and this is true even when we're using
lottery mechanisms
but for other instances we don't know
we can ask how hard it is to compute
these strategies
what computational complexity does it
require
to compute the strategies we described
what if each element has a probing cost
instead of or in addition to the outer
constraint and this is inspired
by the binary model of climb breaking
kleinberg
well if the principal can incentivize
the agent with payments
if they pay for preferable solutions
can the principal do better than without
paying
and what if the principal delegates to
multiple agents simultaneously
can they get those agents to compete
with each other
and get a better outcome for themselves
with that i'll leave you there and thank
you for
listening